for someone that's been in sales for
over 20 years I can tell you from
personal experience men I will never
forget how I reacted the first time I
was about to sell or speak to an
audience just because I was afraid of
rejection I've trained thousands of
people over the years and I've seen so
many different ways people react to
rejection
some get their hands their palms get
sweaty you know they shake you shake
their hands you literally thinks what's
coming down their arms are so sweaty
some people sit outside the opponent
they don't want to go in they're just
waiting for the lights to go off or for
them to cancel because they don't want
to take that sales appointment somebody
goes I start twitching you know what I'm
talking about this starts twitching it
just goes like this and the clients like
what is wrong with this guy's eye some
people call their mom their dad their
boyfriend their girlfriend said I'm
about to go on this appointment what do
I do babe some ticket tequila shot
before listen I can list you all of
these things these are just some of the
things but if you or someone in your
sales team is dealing with this in sales
today's video is for you so look a
couple numbers I want you to be paying
attention as we go through the 10 ways
to handle rejection one is 47% the other
one is 92% remember these two data 47%
92% Oh before I get into it I want to
remind you we got the vault conference
this is the first value team in
conference we announced you wanted it
we're doing it the moment we cross a
million subs we announce that I think a
week and a half ago on the first of
January 2019 and it's going to be done
in May in Dallas this conference is for
entrepreneurs market or seals investors
founders from all over the world that
are coming people from 35 different
countries have already registered the
CEO package officially sold out the only
ones that are left is founder and
founders about to sell out and the rest
of the package is you can go on value
Tim and come on put the link below for
you to get more information about it but
the one thing I can't tell you is do not
wait to get register for this it is
gonna sell out in no time and for some
of you that keep asking me when you come
in India when they come in Australia
when you're gonna come to Japan it all
depends on how many people show up from
Japan from India and Australia and
whatever the other country says then the
next conference may be in your country
having said that click on a link below
get registered but let's get right into
a ten two ways to handle rejection
number one look everything I talk to you
right now about rejection has to do with
perspective everything is perspective
some people have a hard time
dealing with rejection yet at the same
time they do it all the time
look you reject people on a daily basis
every day you're rejecting people matter
of fact today odds are you have already
rejected 30 people today well what do
you mean Pat if you unfollow somebody
that's rejection if you unfriend
somebody that's a rejection if you block
somebody if you press and call to
somebody if somebody sends you texts and
you know you got the text you read the
text they see you read the text you
don't respond to it and the email you
move to jump that's all a form of
rejection so when people start kind of
looking at it and say well I'm so afraid
of rejection what if people reject me
well how about you stop rejecting people
are you finally gonna do that anytime
soon the answer is what of course no cuz
you don't like some people you don't
want to do business so you don't want to
be connected with something but there's
nothing wrong with that so when you
think about it from that perspective it
becomes okay for others to reject you
because you do it 3,200 times every
single day that's point number one
number two two types of rejection one
could hurt your feelings and I
understand that the other one that hurts
your feelings I don't understand that
let me explain if your loved one rejects
you I get it
it could be painful if your kid rejects
you and they and your mother rejects you
your father your husband your wife if
they reject you of course it ought to
hurt a little bit because it's people
you love but if somebody you're trying
to do business with who doesn't know you
who doesn't really care for you who
doesn't love you who doesn't know how
you are as a human being and they don't
yet see you being able to fill a need
for them yet as the key word why are you
so worried if they reject you why are
your feelings hurt they're not your
family they're not your friends you're
somebody that's just a stranger they met
right now the more that relationship
gets deeper they then feel more
committed to wanting to do business with
you but if they do reject you you have
to have perspective and say this wasn't
my mom wasn't my dad wasn't my sister
wasn't my kids wasn't before this is it
I've never I'm probably never gonna meet
this person again why am I upset about
it boom move on in that split second if
you tell your mindset that thing you're
out of it number three life span of
feelings look let me explain it to this
way there's not a single person that
doesn't like being rejected not one
person not trump not Obama nobody likes
being rejected not LeBron not
Kevin Hart nobody likes being rejected
not a single soul but the difference
between the high achievers and the rest
is their lifespan of how long they dwell
on that rejection the average person who
gets rejected they think about it for
days they keep telling everybody about
it my mom my dad my ex I can't believe
they said no I can't believe she said no
and eventually the goal for you is to go
from three days to one day to six hours
to you know one hour to ten minutes to
three seconds I'm hurt I can't believe a
man who held our due next call boom so
your goal is to constantly shorten the
lifespan of the feeling you get from
being rejected it is never gonna go to
zero seconds because when that happens
you're a robot and you ain't gonna be a
robot any any time soon we have feelings
but you want to bring it and make it as
short as you can as possible so you can
move on to the next test number four
anticipation I got this from Tom Hopkins
I think 20 years you got got this from
Tom Hopkins it's four reasons why people
buy and four reasons why people don't
buy I added an additional bonus side
here as well but it's to anticipate so
when you know this why people buy and
you notice why people don't buy you know
how to tell you your presentation or the
way you speak to the client so you're
already addressing it before things come
up so here's four reasons why people buy
Stannis peace of mind security needs I
also put scarcity people like to buy
things that are scarce I want to store
the other day to look at a patek
philippe your watch right the guy starts
explaining to me the history of patek
philippe watch it takes a thousand
people to build one watch let me say
this one more time it takes a thousand
people to build one patek philippe watch
some of you guys are gonna say Pat
that's insane go look it up a thousand
now that's a reason why I cost a couple
hundred thousand dollars to buy their
watch upwards of one of their watches so
for 25 million bucks he started telling
me the scarcity of owning this watch the
status of owning this watch this is not
a peace of mind sale this is a status
and a scarcity sell this is not a
security sale the way he sold security
is these things always keep their value
and they go higher that was their
security but I don't need it and it's
not peace of mind
it was security status and scarcity the
way he sold
so now whatever your product is you got
to look at your product and say why
would somebody buy my product is it a
neat sale is it a security cell is it a
C so a peace of mind cell is it a Santa
so is it a scarcity cell you may not be
selling properly that's why you're
getting rejected so often because you're
approaching would need and your product
is not a need you may be approaching
with scarcity your product is not scarce
it's everywhere you've got to change
that adjustment so you don't get
rejected that often four reasons why
people don't buy fear they're afraid
number two indecision they don't like to
make decisions you don't like to make
decisions number three procrastinate
I'll do it later I'll do it later I'll
do it later or last but not least they
never were they were never asked right
so how do you address this you say look
John Mary the clients that I deal with
they take you know their investments
very seriously and because of that if
they want to make sure they make the
right decisions because they want to be
around the right community so your
product has to do with real estate
couriers are you they want to be around
the dark right community they won't have
a peace of mind that if they buy this
property long-term at least they're
getting something tangible so when you
buy real estate you have something
tangible it's secure because if you're
planning on living this house like you
said for 20 years you don't really have
much to worry about here's how real
estates in the last 20 years and last
but not least I need need to live in a
place to raise your kids with the school
program that we have in this area -
great school and you're going through
this your address again in your
presentation or you're going through
this and you address why some people
don't make decisions then the rejection
level goes lower because you're getting
better at sales number again I can go
deeper in this but I'm just giving you a
glimpse of this year we have a sales
course coming out very soon that's gonna
be three hours of me teaching a through
is you have a stack of notes I'll be
teaching the sales course online sales
course they can go out there and buy
it'll teach everything that I look at
when I'm developing a sales person but
it's not out yet but it'll come out soon
stay tuned for number five let's talk my
number five test your approach change
your approach push the envelope what do
I mean by test your approach you know I
remember when I was coming up and I was
selling I was testing so many different
approaches I'm like let me try this one
out oh wow didn't work let me try this
one a while they let me come meet with
and didn't buy but at least have went
into their house and they were willing
to listen to me but I didn't do what but
I wasn't because I wasn't good here but
at least I got in so
I'm getting better at getting into the
house and getting my foot in the door
this is pretty excited because that's
one skill to getting foot in the door
right but I started testing I mean
there's so many one of the ones I would
do is the following I would say listen
John I can't ask a serious question for
yes how would you like to be five years
younger and they would say I'm sorry
what do you mean how would you like to
be five years younger I want you to go
back five years ago how would you like
to be that age today and it would start
laughing come on Patrick where are you
going with this you know John I'm being
serious with you how would you like to
be five years younger I'd love to be
five years younger what's your point
here's my point John in the next five
years you are going to do business with
me because I'm not gonna stop following
up because I know my product is good I'm
just trying to save you five years by
doing business today and not waiting
five years because that'll make you five
years younger
hahahahaha break the ice boom take their
order happen so many times but I had so
many different approaches that I tested
or there's probably a couple hundred
approaches that we tested and then when
it worked I taught her to my sales team
when it worked I taught it to our sales
organization and it kept going over and
over and over again but keep testing
your approach don't be afraid to test a
little bit don't be afraid to test
around and say why this worked out this
definitely didn't work across this one I
don't bring it up again but you got to
keep testing your approach and
eventually this goes lower number six
follow-up King listen this to me hands
down I saw so many people in sales that
I will compete with that would say some
will someone so what next and I may be a
good philosophy for motivational
speakers to sell you know somebody
doesn't want to buy move on there Ross
your game next customer sounds may be
good too trying to get rookie people to
feel good about being rejected but maybe
you got rejected because you're actually
not good
maybe you got rejected because your
approach isn't good maybe you've got
ridiculous you're not paying attention
to detail so what happens so you want me
to keep telling you're doing a great job
and keep failing because your approach
sucks and not addressing the actual
issue here's a problem for me coming up
I took that philosophy for the first two
three years of sales some will someone
so what next you know it is what they
don't want it let's move on that's not
the case
that's not the case I gave you two stats
earlier 47% of 92% check this out
92% of salespeople quit before the fifth
magical contact they make on follow-up
let me say this one more time
92% of salespeople follow up once not
right now Johnny no profile Oh up twice
not right now Johnny follow up three
times not interested follow up four time
not right now in the fifth time they're
gonna say yes will you stop following up
92% stop right there the fifth one yes
but you stop following I'm not watch
this follow-up has to do with nurturing
a relationship right if you want to go
and have a one-night stand sale that's
fine but it's not gonna lead to leads
but if you want to have a nurturing
relationship to make the sale bigger
that's the follow-up aspect that's the
relationship aspect that's taking notes
that's when you call them from a phone
number you save their number and store
and put their date of birth anniversary
favorite sports team so you remember
stuff about them because you're
nurturing the relationship let me give
you the other stat a person who nurtures
a sales relationship versus one who
doesn't know a relationship the one that
does nurture the relationship and goes
deeper makes a 47% bigger sale than the
one that does an orchard let me say it
again
I sell for fourteen thousand four
hundred but your cell is only ten
thousand dollars because I nurtured the
relationship my sale is 140 thousand
dollar commission your cell is one
hundred thousand dollar commission
because I took that additional step to
nurture the relationship and because
somebody follows up the fifth time
ninety-two percent don't you're in a
whole different league so you look at
this can you imagine if somebody says so
some will someone so what next but they
don't explain this part you just cost
them tens of millions of dollars a
possible Commission so to you watching
this remember 47% 92% if you want to go
deeper in the follow-up King I did a
video a couple years ago called customer
experience versus customer service
something like that only or let's put a
link up here so they know what it looks
like the link will be below you can
click on this as well to go watch it
that'll give you a little bit more
deeper on what's the difference between
customer service and customer experience
number seven role play your approach
with your mentor here's what I mean you
on a sales call doesn't go good instead
of going on your car harping on what
took place and on that 30-minute drive
to your next appointment actually call
your sales manners you call your sales
mentor called yourself whoever it is
that you have you can call that you're
reporting to and say here's what
happened I don't make the sale why this
is what they asked this is what I said
what should I have said can we roleplay
yes I'm the customer Sales Manager you
play the role of me great you say what
the customer said he says whatever back
then he said what the customer said he
says what every stage is rebuttal go
back oh my gosh that's great I didn't
say it then you record it and then he
give the other part customer said this
they said this customer said this you
said oh my goodness that's so amazing
and then you explain whatever areas that
you felt was a leak they may say no
that's not fine that's totally fine
don't worry about that part make this
couple adjustments next time this goes
lower because you got better number
eight Master deaf accuse and trust him
very simple mastery recuse trust them
and you know how the girl next door came
up to me she would always come and say
hey I watch your content I'm in
pharmaceutical sales and I asked her to
go to her sales manager to get the top
20 fa Q's she says nobody has a top 20
FAQ I said what do you mean here Japan
we don't have an FAQ list how do how is
it possible for a sales company to not
have top ten objections and how to
overcome it how is that even possible
half the time is sales leaders and sales
managers running the team don't have a
duplicatable model on how to overcome
every single objection that comes up
which is typically about 20 of them and
once you know the FAQ
you increase the ratio of closing they
don't feel worried about being rejected
because they're gonna close and they're
gonna make money so go master the FAQ
and trust them and if no one has in the
office yet go ask everybody go ask
everybody what's the common objection
what's the common objection what's the
common objection and how do you overcome
it make your own list and start learning
that number nine immediate positive
distraction anytime some rejection would
happen you got to figure out a way to
distract yourself immediately whatever
way you can figure out a way distracted
if it's getting up walking around make
the call back if it's you know changing
the music putting something like rocky
music that fires you up but you gotta
figure out a way to create an immediate
positive distraction so you're not
getting too much
into so you can make that makes call
next appointment number 10 last viñales
make it pass fight or flight let me
explain what I mean by fight or flight
so say you don't know me and I don't
know you okay you I approach you to sell
you your immediate reaction not known
Who I am is one of two things this is
the protection our brain is wired in a
way for it to guard and protect us
the first immediate reaction is the
following I don't know who this is
I'm either fighting you hey what are you
talking about now I'm not interested
fight or I'm flight thank you gone okay
that's immediate your goal is to try to
keep me through flight or fight if you
can keep me past fight or flight then
what comes in place is your ability to
sell me so the way you get past fight or
flight is to make me feel comfortable
knowing I'm in a safe place
dealing with you may be likability may
be commonality may be an area of
interest that you have in me maybe you
did a little bit of research for me
maybe you understand me then my guard
comes down then I'll actually say the
truth which is what do you have to offer
right vs. no not interested hey what are
you doing man I'm not I told you I'm not
interested thank you I walk away if you
can make it pass fight or flight you
actually now become in a territory where
you're going to be judged based on your
ability to be able to sell and I'd much
try to make it there and get to the
point I've known if I can sell or not
but it's so amazing how many salespeople
are great at selling but they don't know
how to get past fight or flight if you
get past fight or flight the rest of its
going to be typically a lot easier than
having to get to do the first part
anyways these are just some of the items
I have there's another video I want you
to watch the videos title the three most
important skill sets to learn as a
salesperson click that link over here as
well and if you haven't register for the
vault click on a link on the link below
to go to value taming comm watch the
video on the website watch the first
video on the website you want find out
exactly what's being taught at the first
vault conference first value team in
conference and if you haven't subscribed
click on the link over here to subscribe
to this channel take everybody bye-bye